you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme cop 26 president alok sharma
tells sky news that north sea gas
extraction is not a solution to the
energy crisis
hundreds of people told to evacuate in
california after a winter wildfire burns
through the big sur
and protesters against hs2 take to the
streets as the transport secretary
announces the third phase of the project
linking london to manchester
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
it's precisely 12 weeks since world
leaders held their summit in glasgow and
today the cop 26 president alok sharma
has urged the world to honor the glasgow
climate pact
but with a cost of living crisis in the
uk and soaring global energy prices
there is a concern that some of the
climate pledges made by world leaders
will be undermined
in an interview with sky news's climate
correspondent hannah thomas peter alex
sharma said that extracting more gas
from the north sea is not the answer to
bringing down energy prices for uk
consumers despite a group of mps calling
for more drilling to go ahead
sharma thank you very much for speaking
to sky news what is the government's
position on more extraction of gas from
the north sea because there are those
who are now making the argument that it
is part of the answer in terms of easing
energy prices gas prices
what what is it that the government
believes about whether that is an answer
we
face a international wholesale gas price
uh you know even if you are extracting
more right now from the north sea basin
uh ultimately the price uh that's going
to be generated is going to be on the
international wholesale gas price so
it's not the answer well if i may so
what i'm saying to you is that the idea
that you will suddenly
change things and that will impact
the price of wholesale gas
internationally i don't think that is a
realistic
there are a
growing group of mps who are
starting to talk about the cost of
living crisis and the energy crisis and
suggesting
that the squeeze on the pockets of
ordinary british people
will mean that the costs of net zero
will be intolerable for them in the
short term what is your assessment of
that argument i think that is a a sort
of separate issue from net zero and you
know i would contend that the way that
you ensure that you keep energy prices
low the way that you ensure that you
have domestic security supply and the
way you ensure that
you are indeed cutting emissions is to
continue to do what we've been doing
increasing our renewables
work and of course
in terms of
base load we want to ensure that we are
seeing more investment in nuclear and
hydrogen and other technologies and that
is happening america
is struggling to get climate change
legislation passed
joe biden said that it was central to
his climate change strategy
he can't do it
how much does that worry you clearly uh
you know it is up to every country to
ensure that they deliver uh the
commitments that they've made in glasgow
and that means delivering domestically
and i very much hope that the us will
get its legislation through one of the
key planks of the glasgow climate pact
was everybody every country agreeing to
come back by the end of 22
with enhanced nationally determined
contributions to to up their ambition
can we have it on record that the uk
is going to do that what we've heard
from the independent committee on
climate change is that the uk's ndc is
aligned to the paris temperature goal of
course we will look at the science and
and see how that develops but the key
issue as the ccc has said is about
delivery and that's what we're going to
be focusing on in the uk that sounds
like you're trying to not say
not commit that you'll come back by the
end of 2022 or something i mean hannah
i'm telling you uh precisely what it
says in the glasgow climate pact and
i've said to you that from a uk
perspective
as the ccc has said is that we are
aligned with the paris temperature goals
and hannah is here with me now so hannah
alexander there insisting that more
drilling in the north sea is not the
answer to the energy crisis so how much
tension is there over this issue i think
we are seeing the government having to
navigate in increasingly
tricky territory you've got this small
group of very well organized
conservative mps and one pier
who are now they're calling themselves
an exclusionary group net zero scrutiny
group they are putting pressure on the
government to extract more gas they say
it'll make gas supplies cheaper and more
secure and we've heard this very firm
position now from from the government
that that is not the answer it's an it's
an international market however there is
real concern within the greener wing of
the conservative party that the argument
about extracting more gas is going to
gain traction particularly as people are
more squeezed when the price cap is
raised and that is going to make it
difficult in turn or more difficult at
least to invest in renewables then
you've got this broader area for
argument around the cost of living
crisis and about whether ordinary people
will be able to find the cash to invest
in boilers and better insulation and
electric cars if they are struggling to
feed themselves or pay their heating
bills now there is real worry about that
becoming a problem for the government
because the treasury has not ruled out
tax increases to help us go green hasn't
ruled out reduced public spending and it
simply cannot cover all of the out of
pocket costs for everybody in this
country as we make this huge transition
and i think what we're seeing here is
that after the big bang of cop 26
everybody had to go home to their own
nations and start to make it work
america's struggling with climate change
legislation the uk has its own
challenges and alok sharma said to me
today i never promised that this was
going to be easy hannah thanks very much
indeed
hundreds of people in the north of
california have been told to evacuate
because of a wildfire in the big sur
area the fire which started on friday
swept through the mountains burning over
1 500 acres of brush and redwood trees
officials say more than 250 firefighters
are currently battling the wildfire
which is being fueled by winds of up to
50 miles an hour nbc correspondent steve
patterson has the latest from california
yeah that wildfire sweeping over an
iconic part of california late in the
season the so-called colorado fire
because it's named after california's
palo colorado canyon grew to more than
700 acres according to cal fire sunday
night intense gusty winds we're talking
up to 50 miles an hour blew the flames
erratically across the area's steep
canyons and famous landmarks like the
picturesque bixby bridge they're on
highway one more than 200 structures
still in the threat zone even as the
winds have now started to ease and die
down and you can add this to a list of
fires burning outside of the peak season
in an area with little to no fire
history so you can imagine how ripe the
vegetation is there as year after year
this footprint gets bigger here in
california the fire's starting to get
even worse this fire now 35 contained
now some on today's other climate news
and cape town has recorded its hottest
temperature ever beating the previous
record by almost three degrees the table
bay area reached 45.2 degrees according
to some experts the previous all-time
record was 42.4 degrees
if confirmed by the authorities it would
mean that cape town was the hottest
location in all of africa on saturday
chinese authorities have warned that
heavy air pollution is likely during the
winter olympics but said emergency plans
were in place to ensure the games were
not disrupted by smog according to the
country's environment ministry data
concentrations of hazardous airborne
particles known as pm 2.5 stood at 205
micrograms per
cubic meter in beijing on monday morning
an alliance of airlines and airports
including lufthansa air france and
amsterdam's skipper airport have called
for the european union to change its
planned climate change legislation
saying it'll make them less competitive
with their non-european rivals
last year the eu presented plans to
enforce stricter rules on co2 emissions
and the use of synthetic fuel blends as
well as the implementation of a kerosene
tax
environmental activists have been
protesting against phase 2b of hs2 which
has been presented to parliament today
it's the final phase of a three-part
plan for the new high-speed railway
network to link london to other parts of
the uk
so let's take a look in more detail at
those plans
construction of phase one connecting
london to the west midlands began in
september 2020 now this phase alone will
involve building more than 300 bridges
and 70 viaducts
the second stage phase 2a connects
birmingham and crew now this has already
been approved by parliament and
construction work is due to begin in
spring 2024.
now in november 2021 the eastern leg of
the high speed line to leeds was
scrapped and today marked the first
parliament reading of the bill for phase
2b which connects crew to manchester now
this phase would cut the journey time
from london to manchester by 55 minutes
to 1 hour and 11 minutes
skies becky cottrell reports from
manchester
when the government talks hs2 leveling
up leads the conversation in manchester
the mayor is behind high-speed rail but
isn't happy with current plans for the
city he wants an underground station to
be built for hs2 passengers
if we try and do everything on the
surface because it's cheaper it would
also require something of a concrete
jungle spreading out to the east
where communities i think would be
completely severed by some of the
infrastructure that would have to be
built so for a whole host of reasons
it's the wrong solution
[Music]
then there are those who oppose the
network entirely this protest in the
city centre may not have attracted huge
numbers but they made their point clear
with this visual metaphor a white
elephant
it's an incredible waste of money the
destruction of the environment is
absolutely inequitable hs2 will
say that they're going to mitigate the
damage that they do environmentally but
by definition you can't you can't
mitigate for irreplaceable landscapes so
we're talking about uh ancient woodlands
we're talking about
destroying uh
landscapes that have evolved over
centuries karen wilding worries the cost
of a ticket will mean only wealthy
people can afford to travel on the
high-speed network
i can't afford to train trains even as
it is at the moment i have to go by
coach okay so basically our transport
system is the problem and hs2 is not
solving our transport system it is not
going to give us the choice to get out
of our cars
the government insists their plan will
get people off the motorways and onto
the railway
i think residents are behind it because
they understand that it's going to mean
not just quicker journeys to places like
manchester birmingham and london but it
will just mean more capacity on local
routes so actually those quicker local
journeys are more frequent
many in the north disagree the
government recently scrapped a new
high-speed rail link across the penins
in favor of upgrading existing lines
leveling up once again boiling down to
how much those in power are willing to
spend
becky cottrell sky news manchester
do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by
deputy director at the energy and
climate intelligence unit sepi golzari
monroe and journalist and author david
wallis wells and we'll be discussing the
solutions to the energy crisis and the
latest emergency measures introduced by
china to curb air pollution before the
winter olympics
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
deputy director at the energy and
climate intelligence unit sepi golzari
monroe and journalist and author david
wallace well said good evening to both
of you nice to see you both
so the solution to the energy crisis in
the uk is not to drill for more oil and
gas that's what cop president alok
sharma told us today following repeated
calls from some conservative mps to do
just that
well international gas prices are sky
high today in part at least due to
putin's russia restricting the flow so
what's the solution should every country
be energy independent if possible be
that with oil gas or renewables
sepi what do you think there are some
voices in the conservative party who say
get rid of green levies people can't
afford those at the moment because of
the squeeze on their incomes they also
say that we should increase the amount
of gas that's being drilled for in the
north sea
to try to get over the energy crisis
alex sharma says that's not the way to
go
how much tension and split is there over
this issue not just in government but
but more broadly do you think
honestly anna i think it's a bit of a
red herring as hannah said it's a very
small uh minority of uh conservative mps
most conservative mps indeed most of uh
the the british public uh really
supports uh climate action it's the top
most concern uh for the british public
in uh you know in the issues of climate
environment so it really is a red
herring and i think the the reality and
the reality that most uh serious
politicians uh who are looking at this
issue
understand is that it's our continued
reliance on polluting fossil fuels that
are dependent on the kind of uh work of
let's put up with the unfriendly regimes
so you know it's coming up for a year
now since putin's russia began its
latest round of geopolitical game
playing restricting gas supplies into
europe and contributing to the gas price
spike so actually the best way to reduce
our energy bills is to reduce our
reliance on gas by insulating our homes
uh improving our housing stock and
continuing to move towards the homegrown
and clean and cheap elect new renewables
in the electricity system
and david you're in new york at the
moment so what about the u.s point of
view how much consensus is there there
about
managing transition but keeping prices
down for consumers what's the picture
there
well as i think is almost always the
case on climate we're a little less
progressive in our collective outlook
than you see in the uk or across europe
but i think most energy experts would
agree that the um the price crisis that
we're seeing now not just in the uk but
really all across the world is not the
result of climate policies um
drilling for more oil would not
meaningfully address um and produce more
gas would not meaningfully address the
short-term problem um and if we're
thinking about trying to build a
smoother transition to a more stable
energy future a decade from now it seems
pretty clear i think from from all um
expert perspectives that the best path
to that is to radically expand our um
our renewable build out so that
over the next five or seven or ten years
um we're not as dependent on um petrol
states like uh like russia or saudi
arabia um for our energy needs that's
not to say that every country can or
should go entirely energy independent um
but it is it does happen to be the case
that the international alliances that
renewable energy pulls you into tend to
be alliances um with socially and
politically more friendly regimes who
are less prone to this kind of
gamesmanship and i think as a result um
a more renewable energy say two or
five-year plan is going to get us to a
much
better
cheaper
place when it comes to energy so
separate you'll both agree that
renewables in future will make bills
cheaper what about in the short term
what about now just insulating your loft
isn't going to keep people's energy
prices
energy bills much lower is it
well actually we've had the eci you've
got a report out today that shows that
if the uk government had continued with
its plans to insulate homes there were
modest plans uh but
nonetheless had continued with those
plans nine million uk households would
be paying 170 pounds less on their
energy bills this year so actually the
cost of not acting of not insulating our
homes has added an eye watering amount
to people's bills and that's that's not
insignificant and that's a modest
proposal that was back in 2013 actually
if you ramped up the insulation program
you could reach many more households and
significantly reduce their bills so i
think there are
schemes that are very popular with the
public that could be
started and ramped up you know
very very soon because we know that
actually you know experts say that the
gas prices are going to remain high for
at least 18 months to two years so we
can make significant inroads if we
actually just get the policies in place
okay let's move on to our next issue now
because chinese authorities are to
impose dramatic emergency restrictions
on polluting businesses and vehicles
ahead of the winter olympics in order to
avoid high levels of air pollution the
winter weather conditions are very
unfavorable according to chinese
authorities so what does it tell us
about their long-term commitment to
tackling air pollution and david first
of all tell us why air pollution in
china is so bad it was home to 42 of the
world's 100 most polluted cities last
year and that didn't even include
beijing which is having such problems
with smog now
yeah you know india's the the country in
the world with the worst air pollution
problems but um china is is um not doing
very well i hide there largely it's
because of industrial production and
coal burning um but it also has to do
with weather patterns and um and the
urban density around um old coal plants
so they've actually tried to do some
long-term planning they've moved a lot
of that coal production away from cities
which is one reason why many fewer
people are dying from air pollution uh
now in in beijing and then we're in 2013
2014 um but as these measures show it's
obviously not sufficient to make even a
couple of weeks um comfortably you know
reliably clear of not just um you know
unsightly but but lethal potentially
lethal pollution well yes and sephie
what do you make of that step to to
get polluting companies to stop
stop their business short term in order
to get some results what does it say
about the effect of an international
event like this is it a force for good
or is this just a short-term fix and
china will go back to its its same
habits as soon as it's over
i mean it is an interesting point isn't
it the fact that china clearly cares so
much about international opinion that
it's going to go to these great lengths
to to clean up its act albeit for a
short time uh before it finds itself
hosting uh athletes and media outlets i
mean that's informative in and of itself
and i think we saw in the international
climate process that china does care
about global opinion and how it's
perceived so that could lead to a bit
more of a virtuous cycle of peer
pressure obviously this is a short-term
uh
you know measure um and uh you know but
these things can lead to some more
embedded action in the future do you
think that's right are you encouraged by
it at all david i mean or is it sort of
green washing on an international stage
because china's in a strange position
isn't it it's the most polluting country
in the world and yet it's also investing
a huge amount of renewables
i think the medium-term view is that
china's been tackling air pollution
relatively aggressively by global
standards they're still far from the era
that we would be happy to be breathing
in the uk or the us but they've made
huge gains over the last decade and
everything suggests they're going to
continue doing that it's not sufficient
it leaves many people behind
but i don't think this is just a
short-term green washing episode they're
trying to make themselves look best for
a brief period but the longer term
trajectory is encouraging i will just
point to the bigger picture you just
flashed a little graphic on the screen
showing that um the particular matter in
beijing regularly exceeds who guidelines
95 of the world has air that where the
particular matter exceeds the whole
guideline so while china is in a worse
place than almost everywhere else aside
from india this is not just a problem
confined to china it's a problem that
we're seeing in london in new york all
across the west all across the
developing world and it's one we really
need to be dealing with alongside the
challenge of climate change audience and
sophie very briefly we've been
discussing just that with clean air
zones being discussed
expansion of them in london and
manchester as well in england
i mean do you think that beijing's
issues will highlight the problems of
pollution one that some people say isn't
talked enough about
yeah i mean you know i think it's it's
such a it's a factor that impacts so
many people across the world and you
have seen movements in the uk in europe
in africa in asia
really trying to raise awareness about
it but you're right it's not it's not up
there um as high as perhaps it should be
on the agenda given its severe negative
impacts on health um and so possibly
this could actually you know with with
the world's um media and the world's
eyes on beijing could help really raise
the issue
fantastic well sepi glossary monroe
david wallace wells always good to talk
to you thanks very much indeed for your
time
and tomorrow i'll be joined by director
of research at chatham house bernice lee
and scientist and author michael mann
but that's it for me thank you for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]